to my delight and surprise i actually
knew who the mass singer was which on
occasion is not
the case usually it's just like i will
turn to my kids and say who
who is that
but i know this guy not only because
i rooted like crazy for this guy when he
was and still
is the last quarterback
to take the jets to an nfc championship
afc championship game in almost
the whole damn way but also covered him
in his years in usc coming into the
uh ranks of professional ranks and he's
also just an all-around great guy who i
do believe is also
uh head over heels in love with sweat
taylor like i am as well
he is the unmasked baby allen
by baby alien pardon me the unmasked
baby alien
here on the rich eisen show mark sanchez
how are you mark
rich i couldn't be any better buddy that
was that's really funny what'd your kids
say they finally
they finally uh respect me as a
celebrity no
no they were happy for me that it was a
new york jet that got unmasked
they were happy for me they were happy
though they were happy for me
you know mark but uh i was like
come on you got to be kidding me
congratulations that was a
that must have been a blast for you this
whole it was so fun
it was so fun and you talk about i mean
you nailed it
it is a family show my gosh and getting
ready for the show
because of the puppet element yeah i had
to practice a lot
with this puppet just to make it come to
life and and
give it personality baby aliens they
gave me
yeah exactly they gave me a fake puppet
and a puppeteer coach named ron
yeah ron the puppeteer we would zoom he
was on like cranky anchors he's been on
the muppets like
the puppeteer of all puppeteers okay and
he had this like whole method that he
would put me through
just to like start just to begin before
i even put my hand in the puppet right
and we would zoom constantly we'd zoom a
couple times a week
for hours and i'm learning how to use
this
thing and he's like the whole thing is
you just gotta practice when you read
when you listen to music when you listen
to podcasts you just gotta practice and
practice you know responding to things
and blah blah blah and bring the puppet
to life that was this whole thing
so now i'm reading books to my kids
okay every night i have this incredible
video of us reading about
i think it was like volcanoes or
earthquakes or something like that yeah
and i'm going through the emotions of
learning something new
as this baby alien puppet right like i'm
from outer space so now i have to give
this puppet
a personality and i'm showing you know
surprise and
uh you know sadness when i can't
pronounce the word and trying to use the
accent and
all that stuff so i'm practicing my
material on my kid
right before bed for months trying to do
this
so finally he got to see it last night
he finally understood why i'm running
around the house with a heavy backpack
to simulate
the uh weight of the costume running
around with a silly puppet
and singing at the top of my lungs over
the sonos
on a karaoke machine in my living room
so it all made sense
last night wow how old is your son
he's uh he'll be four in november oh man
did he know that you're the baby alien
yeah
i mean so he had no idea you were about
to be unmasked
on tv no he had no clue but he knew
everything leading up to it
so as soon as that happened he just said
we gotta call grandpa we gotta call
grandma and tell him
that amazing that is that's why you do
it that's why you do it
that is why you do it that is so great i
mean what a moment that you could have
with your kid
and your family that is but the singing
aspect of it mark i mean um
how would you how would you rate
yourself on that side of things mark
listen
i'm very realistic i knew what kind of
my
range was and i said you know i just
want to maximize the range that i have i
don't want to try and
you know aim for something that's
unattainable let's be realistic with
this thing but i think there's a little
bit of talent that can be developed even
further
and the vocal coach said yeah like you
you're i'm actually surprised because a
lot of people come on things they can
either sing
better than they than they really can
or you know they they you know downplay
themselves and they can actually sing
really well
and she's like you have a pretty good
gauge on on your voice and so let's just
work within these notes that you can hit
and we'll make them the best notes you
can and she said with the puppet with
the you know the costume and all that
kind of stuff
everything else will take care of itself
and so i felt like
i felt really good right i feel sure
like i maximized my potential
well i'm walking off stage and there
goes seahorse
trotting onto the to the stage and
you're not supposed to hear the other
performances i still don't know who the
other contestants are
they keep everything so no kidding and
they like shuffle you past everybody
you don't see anything i have no clue
and
i hear her as i'm undressing and you're
not supposed to hear the other
performances but this costume is so hard
to get off
this baby alien costume so it takes like
three people to help me get out of it
and we're taking our time and boom
seahorse starts performing
and i said you have got to be kidding me
i'm like i'm in the group with celine
dion or somebody who can sing like
celine
this is crazy i looked over the dude
as a competitive jerk i'm like hey who
put me in this group that's right yes
bro
name straight she's
[Laughter]
check right because i was on this you
know emotional high feeling like yeah
man we knocked it out this is great
and then just like boom back to earth
buddy well at least you had to know mark
at that moment in time that
at least you were better than gronk at
this thing uh
you know i mean exactly my kids are
normally guessing who's this who's
that and we're so way off we everybody
knew that was gronk
literally from the first second that
that gronk opened his mouth
but last season i think it was the tiger
last season yeah yeah yeah
you got you're better than gronk there
no i appreciate it and i think antonio
brown lasted one week too
in the first season right so you're
you're in good standing
mark you really are you did all right i
did all right you did all you did you
did all right
um well uh that's this is great i mean
this is a total blast
um i i will i will since you're here uh
the day after le'veon bell released
uh by the jets yeah i i i i don't know
what to make of
of what's going on with the organization
mark i don't know if you're tight with
them if you're still
at all associated with the organization
or what your two cents are and where
things currently stand on five the whole
thing
seems to be falling apart here mark
yeah so i think part of the issue is
they've
they've invested in a couple different
players and things didn't pan out
whether
you know whether it's because of injury
or poor performance but cj mosley
and le'veon bell just didn't really pan
out right and so they had a chance to
just
cut ties cut the dead weight and move on
which is
inevitable with a new gm so
then it brings the question like okay if
this season is
more or less lost then what are we doing
with sam
and that's that's my real concern
obviously we have
a great bond he's a good friend of mine
we work out together and
and i want everything i want the best
for him and i've lived what he's going
through their roster right now is no
different than what we had in
2012 2013 or whatever my last couple
years there
there's no household names there's
nobody you know that a defensive
coordinator is looking at their offense
like damn okay are we gonna double this
guy are we gonna roll coverage like what
are we gonna
nobody's doing that so you can't expect
these guys to compete
and develop a quarterback with that
going on in the building so now it's
you know what's best for sam what's best
for the organization
uh you know how bad is his shoulder
injury and and i understand why they why
they cut ties with le'veon now
you know i think things are hard enough
but then you're you know doing the
social media stuff
like criticizing play calling or
agreeing with criticizing a play calling
or how everyone down
it's just messy and in a media market
like that
you just don't want that you don't need
it anywhere but if you're in
jacksonville if you're in you know
somewhere else
it's not the same here it's just a
cancer and you can't have that
it doesn't help you move forward so i
think that was just kind of
joe douglas sending a message to
everybody like hey i understand we're
you know we're not very good but that
doesn't fly here no doubt
no doubt i i get it too um you know and
i'll just
walk through the front door here with
you you know uh because again you're
also an analyst a collegiate college
football analyst for espn i mean you
know you know the landscape
about everything here from being a
quarterback with the jets and and who's
going to be potentially number one
overall
um i i think what they should do is let
sam free i think they're breaking him i
think he might be broken
um he is uh i i've met him and
i second the emotion you obviously know
him better he's a great human he
deserves better than this he's somebody
who showed up on his first day of being
a jet he went to a children's hospital
that's exactly what you want
out of a face of a franchise exactly but
there they have nobody around him right
now there is no way to properly evaluate
him he's in danger personally i think
out there and um i think they should
trade him at this deadline right now
give him a new spot put him in a spot
where somebody can get him cheap
and put him in a quarterback room uh
with with a with a real veteran and let
him just sit back and learn
and start again somewhere else and draft
trevor lawrence i wonder what what you
think about that
yeah i don't think that's a terrible
idea actually i
think i'd be great i just don't know if
that will happen right because you still
have them you can exercise the fifth
year right
i believe yes am i correct on timing you
are indeed sir
so i mean if you can and it's still not
some crazy number and you can still get
the first pick
like why wouldn't you let those guys
compete and then
see what happens now i don't think
that's the best for sam if you have just
sam's best interest in mind yeah i think
you're right i think he does go
somewhere else
where he's going to match up with a
coordinator who's going to love to have
him they'll just get a
gift you know right in their lap no
doubt and christmas come early if it
happens at the trade deadline so
that would be perfect for him to develop
somewhere where they're going to build
around him
but if he's constantly looking over his
shoulder especially with a new gm like i
ran into this
uh when they drafted geno smith like as
soon as mike tannenbaum left
there's no promises there's no
guarantees and with
with me because the the guy running the
show
has no ties to me and now i'm just
another commodity like anybody else he's
not emotionally invested in me
and so that's it and now sam's in that
position so you just
like you said you want the best form and
i'd love for him to land somewhere
where he's appreciated and they build
around him because he has
i know for a fact he has the talent to
do it i've seen him work out with josh
allen
all off season the last couple years
these guys make the same throws it's
just josh allen is working with
household names
like they draft and develop and then
they played the free agent game
and won right they gambled on free
agents and won
cole beasley stefan diggs john brown
like
the player then they're drafting players
they have a good running back in
singletary and they draft zach mock from
utah it's a baller
so i mean this is what you want for your
quarterback
the jets just need to take notes on that
and and figure out how to build around a
quarterback i don't if trevor lawrence
comes in and has the same situation as
sam
he'll get wasted too and it's it's
really too bad it's all about how you
build around that guy
mark you the man i appreciate connecting
with you here
uh let's do this more often i really
would appreciate that it was a delight
seeing you underneath the
baby alien mass congrats and having that
moment with your family
and being able to do something where you
step out of your your lane if you will
uh all good thanks for the call you take
care yes sir let's talk soon let's do
that that's mark sanchez everybody right
here at mark underscore sanchez on
twitter and instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here